so jetzt wieder mit only nahen es ist
wirklich phänomenal wir haben so viele
dinge gelernt die einfach komplett
falsch sind
sie werden immer weiter getragen aber
sie basieren auf einem fehler oder auf
aussagen die einfach unüberlegt gemacht
wurden manchmal gibt es ein
flüchtigkeitsfehler die die journalisten
passieren auf mehr
aber es gibt falsche fakten nicht
alternative die immer weiter getragen
werden aber nicht stimmen die sache mit
dem spieler zum beispiel aber dazu
gleich mehr in klicks zum ziel kommen
ja das mit dem spinat war ein riesen
missverständnis aber erst mal unsere top
ten der falschen fakten auf der ces ist
mega gefährlich sind kratzer in einer
teflonpfanne sind dadurch nehmen wir
teflon auf und das ist hochgiftig das
ist echt quatsch mit soße oder eben in
diesem fall teflon mit soße teflon ist
ein ganz normaler kunststoff politiker
flur ethylen kurz ptfe wie jeden anderen
kunststoff auch können wir den essen
ohne dass irgendwas passiert da sind
halt nicht gut für die umwelt wobei die
menge die bei teflon fahren in die
umwelt gerät recht gering ist im
vergleich zum beispiel zu plastiktüten
die einzige gefahr die von teflon
ausgeht ist dann wenn teflon zu lange zu
sehr ab einer temperatur von 260 grad
celsius wird es gefährlich die
inhalation dieser dämpfer kann so
genanntes von fieber auslösen lieber
einem grippalen effekt bekommt man
fieber schüttelfrost und husten aber nur
kurz allerdings sterben wir auch vögel
die sich im gleichen raum befinden an
den dämpfen
die neuen der mond scheint nachts ja das
ist eine wirklich unüberlegte aussage
ein blick an den himmel belehrt uns
eines besseren 2 ist der tagsüber wegen
der hellen sonne nicht so oft zu sehen
aber wer mal öfter und genauer hinschaut
wird feststellen dass der mond auch
tagsüber scheint es würde auch keinen
sinn machen
die mondbahn existiert der komplett
unabhängig von der umlaufbahn der erde
um die sonne auf der 18 umwelt wird
immer mehr verstrahlt
zwar haben wir mit großen problemen zu
kämpfen der überfischung atomare
verseuchung oder thema hier letztlich
das große focus werben aber zum beispiel
deutschlands flüsse
sie waren noch nie so sauber seit der
industrialisierung total verdreckte
kloaken gibt es nicht mehr und ich habe
sie noch erlebt und habe dann mitten
ihnen danach die umwelt aufsicht
alarmiert aber das gehört inzwischen der
vergangenheit an
die luft ist auch besser geworden und so
weiter die 7
die sonne geht im osten auf und im
westen unter jahr aber nur an zwei tagen
im jahr
dann wenn es ein edwin option gibt
tagundnachtgleiche dann überschreitet
die sonne den himmelsäquator und nur an
diesem tag gc exakt im osten auf und im
westen unter das ist zum einen um den
anfang des märz herum und
den 21 september an allen anderen tagen
geht für irgendwo an einer anderen
stelle am horizont auf und unter also ab
dem 21
es im südosten und ab dem 21 september
im nordosten die decks der polarstern
ist der hellste stern am nachthimmel
er ist es nicht der ist noch nicht mal
unter den top ten und auch nicht in den
top 20 nicht in den top 30 ja er ist der
49 hellste stern am nachthimmel also
weit davon entfernt besonders hell zu
sein
in seinem bereich in dem erscheint ist
der leicht zu finden weil ich einfach
nur auf den kompass sehen muss aber
besonders hell ist er eben nicht auf der
5 wer passend der mensch hat fünf sinne
da sind aber einige unter die räder
gekommen gut die fünf sinne von denen
wir immer wieder reden stehen für mich
im vordergrund sehen riechen schmecken
hören fühlen ja aber da gibt es noch
einige mehr sind jahr verglichen mit
einem smartphone unsere sensoren wer
wird auch beim smartphone
wenn du viel mehr als 5 wobei es nicht
schmecken oder riechen kann aber es hat
zum beispiel einen sensor für die lage
im raum den haben wir auch den
gleichgewichtssinn heißt auch sogar so
verstehe gar nicht warum wir den bei der
aufstellung immer vergessen
hinzu kommen schmerz durch oder erkennt
das gefühl von schmetterlingen im bauch
das ist ein will mit dem unser
solarplexus über unsere gefühle
informiert das gehört zum bisher ahlen
will der wahrnehmung der inneren organe
sehr spannend die proprio rezeption es
handelt sich um den sinn mit dem wir
ziemlich exakt die lage unserer muskeln
im raum wahrnehmen können nur damit
können wir zum beispiel mit
geschlossenen augen an unsere nase
fassen so er probiert es mal aus es
funktioniert dank proprio sektion wir
haben einen sinn für temperatur und das
sind jetzt schon elf sinne auf die ich
komme fallen euch noch weitere ein
schreibt sie unbedingt in die kommentare
dann mache ich ein video speziell über
die wille des menschen wie hier die
evolution ist bloß eine theorie eben die
evolutionstheorie und es gibt noch viele
andere theorien maike pence der
vizepräsident der usa verbreitet diesen
quatsch zum beispiel
er ist damit komplett auf dem holzweg
ist der mich nur diese eine theorie und
weil die menschen
bibel früher mal geschichten
aufgeschrieben haben sind das noch lange
keine theorien oder irgendetwas das für
uns eine quelle von geschehen sein
könnte die bibel ist die sammlung der
geschichten mit denen sich die menschen
damals die komplexe welt erklärt haben
wir hatten ja nichts anderes aber mit
wissenschaft oder wissen hat das rein
gar nichts zu tun
und solche geschichten die gibt es ja
überall auf der welt auf die meyer
hatten sie das wissen wir spätestens
2012 und viele andere
aber es bleibt dabei es sind geschichten
und die wissenschaftler haben ja in
anderen fachgebieten durchaus
unterschiedliche theorien aber hier bei
der evolutionstheorie sind alle
überprüfungen studien untersuchungen und
so weiter und fordert immer auf das
gleiche ergebnis gekommen die evolution
hat stattgefunden
da es keine theorie im sinne von
möglichkeit sondern eine theorie im
sinne von überprüft und zwar unzählige
male auch von skeptikern und damit
bewiesen und gewiss wie ist wahrheit
und da sollte man sich auch nicht von
irgendwelchen quatsch karten irritieren
lassen die können gerne etwas anderes
glauben aber dass es eben glauben
der gehört bekanntlich in die kirche und
auf keinen fall in die schule
wie bereits am nachthimmel können wir
millionen sterne sehen leider nicht ist
gerade mal rund 3000 und wenn wir in
einer stadt sind dann reduziert sich
diese zahl deutlich durch die
luftverschmutzung werden wir hier
geblendet und weniger sterne 50 gerne
wird übrigen keller als zwei mack und
damit auch in der stadt zu sehen
die ähnlichkeit von stern wird in
magnituden angegeben und umso heller
gewinnt desto niedriger ist dieser wert
die sonne strahlt zum beispiel mit minus
26 8 max und der polarstern mit 197
markt damit kommt er wir hatten uns ja
gerade unter die top 50 sterne mit mehr
als 2 mark twain kinder sehen übrigens
deutlich mehr sterne weil sie größere
pupillen haben als erwachsene aus der 2
die sonne leuchtet gelb ein riesen
irrtum wie ist zwar selber zwerg
qualifiziert aber das hat nicht so viel
mit ihrer wahrgenommen farbe zu tun die
in dem ich weiß und wenn wir als
astronauten im weltraum wären würden wir
sie als weiß leuchtend wahrnehmen aber
in die sonne zu schauen ist ja auch
ziemlich gefährlich auch hier auf der
erde kann man wie bei leuchten sehen
wenn sie sich nämlich an ihrem höchsten
punkt
befindet aber bitte nicht ohne filter m
über meer schauen die gelbe
farbwahrnehmung rührt von der
zusammensetzung der erdatmosphäre durch
die streuung in der erdatmosphäre wird
überwiegend der violette und blaue
anteil der sichtbaren sonnenstrahlung
gestreut das auge sieht dieses blau aber
eben am gesamten himmel auch dieses
licht ist sonnenlicht was aber dann noch
direkt von der sonne kommt ist halt
nicht ohne diese farb anteile so dass
sie sonne eher gelb oder orange wird auf
der eins und das ist wirklich ein sehr
lustiges missverständnis und wenn man
darüber nachdenkt haben denkt man echt
wie konnte ich nur so blöd sein die tage
werden im sommer länger und im winter
kürzer klar gibts ja kein zweifel ist
die aussage hätte auch ich sofort
unterschrieben
sie ist ein blödsinn wann beginnt der
sommer richtig am 21 juni
und was ist auch am 21 juni es ist der
längste tag des jahres also der tag mit
der längsten sonnenscheindauer detail
manchmal auch ein tag früher oder später
danach werden die tage kürzer also
während des gesamten sommers wort und im
winter ist es genauso aber auch wirklich
exakt das gleiche was ist am 21
dezember genau der winteranfang und der
kürzesten tag des jahres die tage werden
also im winter länger auf der
südhalbkugel die daten übrigens
lediglich vertauscht alles andere ist
exakt so ich fand das einen wahnsinn
fritz vom bifie tatsachen wir ausgehen
hier war gar nicht stimmen hammer ach ja
der spinat
da gab es mal einen schreibfehler und
alle sachen bora spinat enthält aber
viel eisen den müssen kinder essen
der ist aber gesund aber es war eben nur
ein schreibfehler exakt genau ein
kommafehler spinat ist zwar gesund aber
mehr eisen bekommen wir durch ihn nicht
da sollten wir lieber rostige messer
verwendet habt ihr noch ideen für
weitere solche falschen fakten schreibt
sie in die kommentare
ich mache dann ein weiteres video zum
thema wenn er sich verpassen wollt dann
wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht mir einen auf die
glocke zu geben und was haltet ihr von
meinen haaren endlich sehen wir wieder
ordentlich aus st lucia money no
hier findet ihr genau da den berliner
sammlung der private wenn er sagt dass
er von mir bekommt gibt es zehn prozent
rabatt und wir werden beim nächsten mal
die haare kurz
ausgeschnitten waren wenn sie allesamt
bleibt dran